I stopped labeling things as good or bad
because if I'm failing that means I'm
about to go through learning failure
leads to learning learning leads to
success success leads to complacency
complacency leads to failure I remember
thinking that like there was a
destination the actual entrepreneurial
cycle is is not linear it's cyclical
that's why I talk about entrepreneurship
in terms of Seasons recognizing that you
are not above the cycle but that that
cycle is inevitable failure learning
success complacency the goal is if you
can identify that how quickly can you
get back to learning success and try and
skip the complacency step altogether